talk to us about the significance of all
of this so it's a huge deal and it comes
in a new context for Disney World
Disneyland Disney World and Disney in
their theme park business because
they're facing a new competitor
Universal has had some really big
success with their Harry Potter
development down in Orlando so and and
and these guys are looking at that
thinking we know if there's a new player
out there they've got to contend with
did they force their hand I think that
this was part of the plan of what made
the Star Wars properties the Lucasfilm
property is so valuable to them but this
was ahead of those announcement since I
had and it was personal this
announcement is was a long while coming
right we suspected as much when they
acquired Lucas when they got a deal with
the city of Anaheim to promise to invest
a certain amount of money I think as a
billion dollars to get a break from the
new ticket taxes in Anaheim that was a
big sign that they were gonna about to
put a lot but this this comes before
they've left a big movie going up in the
fall the new holiday movie the new Star
Wars Episode the JJ Abrams directed
vehicle but at the same time that
they're trying to dial back expectations
on that movie saying let's not get ahead
of ourselves we don't want the movie to
do well we don't want everyone to be
penciling in some really big numbers we
don't know that we can do so this is
part of their also expansion of other
resort other parks as well right I mean
they're betting big in China the
Shanghai may be even as big a bad maybe
even bigger bet for them because on some
level these the additions to Disney
World and Disneyland are just that
additions where Shanghai there they're
moving Shanghai is going to be huge for
them and I think that one of the things
you see them doing is looking for
editorially they're looking for the
kinds of stories and their movies that
can translate well into theme parks that
are not cut so controversial as so they
can get themselves into China and give
and grow that market okay so all of this
then I guess it's it's a no brainer it's
not much of a gamble for mr. Uyghur well
it's a big gamble because of the games
aren't if the rides aren't great if
they're not done well you know we saw a
similar dynamic with Michael Eisner rust
to put up Disneyworld Hollywood and that
happened at the same time that they had
a new competitor and Universal coming in
they rushed to get that out it wasn't
very good it's been a very unpopular
destination yeah it's one it's an
adjacent park that's sort of a little
further south in Orlando that it's just
not the hot spot indeed star wars is
going to replace that does some people
look back and see as a mistake
the rides have to be great but we don't
have little kids
mark is a Star Wars Grouch I actually
like the originals but what's gonna be
trying to picture Mark Crumpton but it's
all the ride in the suit-and-tie much
keep your arms inside the vehicle it
applies the same to mark the bar
recreating the bar I do not know if they
will have real alcohol one of it but
wait one of the hits at Universal and a
Harry Potter ride is is the beer the
butter beer which is exactly that they
drinkin in a Harry Potter books so one
of the hits at the theme park for the
adults is this non-alcoholic beer adidas
or giving their kids the non-alcoholic
beer maybe I don't know they tell the
kids it's not alcohol but I think this
is very clearly reaction which one at
Universal also Disney's a behemoth the
stocks did so well I hope it's done so
well under Bob Iger we'll see if it's
this a success
we might bet that it will be